super hydrophobe wende in hamburg eine
partielle sonnenfinsternis in europa und
ein solarflugzeug überall auf dem globus
fünf spannende neuigkeiten aus der
wissenschaft gibt es jetzt bei den krieg
zum klopfen st pauli pinkl zurück die
berühmte reeperbahn hat ein problem seit
jahren pinkeln betrunkene im hamburger
viertel gegen jede nur erdenkliche wand
doch damit soll nun schluss sein denn st
pauli pinkelt jetzt zurück mit einem
wissenschaftlichen trick viele wände in
sankt pauli wurden in den letzten wochen
mit einem speziallack besprüht dieser
ist super hydrophob das heißt er ist
extrem wasserabweisend so sehr sogar
dass der urin der betrunkenen pinkler
direkt wieder zurück geflogen kommt
eintrittswinkel gleich austritts winkel
ist für viele feierlustige wohl zu
kompliziert trotz der warnschilder
pinkelten viele gegen die wände und
waren im nachhinein ziemlich angepisst
ob der lack hilft die straßen auf dauer
sauber zu halten
das wird sich noch zeigen mit dem
solarflugzeug um die welt der nachfolger
der solar impuls hat die spannweite
eines airbus 380 ist aber nur 0 6
prozent so schwer wie der riesenjet zwei
piloten wollen mit dem solar impuls 2 am
samstag zur ersten weltumrundung mit
einem solarflugzeug aufbrechen
35.000 km richtung osten obwohl der 25
flugtage für die historische reise
vorgesehen sind rechnen die piloten
damit erst in rund fünf monaten wieder
an ihren startpunkt anzukommen
für eine komplette weltumrundung in
einen trip ist das flugzeug noch nicht
ausgereift genug aber ein paar tausend
kilometer müssen
ausführliche tests durchgeführt werden
um die sicherheit der piloten zu
gewährleisten innerhalb des
solarflugzeugs befinden sich eine
toilette ein business class sitz und
zumindest genug platz um sich hinzulegen
neues fossil wirbelt historische daten
durcheinander wir sind älter geworden
ein kleines stück knochen das von
forschern in äthiopien gefunden wurde
ist bis zu 28 millionen jahre alt und
gehörte einen frühen menschen der
gattung homo also zu unserer gattung
bisher waren alle funde der gattung aber
maximal 24 millionen jahre alt forscher
gehen jetzt davon aus dass aus der
gattung australopithecus der auch das
berühmte skelett lucy angehört die
gattung des homo hervorging
doch anscheinend existiert die
menschliche gattung homo bereits 400.000
jahre länger als bisher angenommen
die forscher sind sich noch nicht sicher
ob der neue fund die bisherigen
vermutungen über die spezies verändert
unsere gattung homo sapiens existiert
übrigens erst seit etwa 200.000 jahren
und gilt als die einzige überlebende art
der linie homo so jetzt kommt es ein zu
einer wirklich bahnbrechenden erkenntnis
neue studie zur durchschnittlichen
penislänge ja eine neue studie über die
durchschnittliche länge und den umfang
des penis sorgt für diskussionen
im gegensatz zu beinahe allen anderen
studien bisher basiert diese
ausschließlich auf daten die geschultes
fachpersonal persönlich gemessen hat
viele bisherige studien ließen auch
messungen der männer selber zu doch
anscheinend hatten die immer falsch
gemessen denn das ergebnis der neuen
studie überrascht 13 12 zentimeter soll
das durchschnittliche erigiertes glied
lang sein das sind etwa zwei zentimeter
weniger als die angaben der meisten
anderen studien daraus lässt sich
schließen dass viele männer bei ihren
angaben etwas geflunkert haben
außerdem biete die studie ein paar
interessante statistiken gerade einmal
fünf prozent der männer haben einen
penis der 16 cm oder länger ist auch
jeder zwanzigste mann muss mit weniger
als zehn zentimetern leben die
restlichen 90 prozent befinden sich also
zwischen 11 und 15 15
entschuldigung
ich habe nur eine frage und das geht mir
schon lange im kopf herum ab wo wird
denn eigentlich gemessen an der
rückseite also an der am beginn des
schwellkörpers oder vorne wo der penis
sich vom unterleib abhebt wer kriegt das
raus ich will es endlich mal wissen wie
lamm einer ist übrigens gibt es mass
kondome für unterschiedliche penis
umfänge aber das ist ein anderes thema
partielle sonnenfinsternis am
zwanzigsten jahr 2015 wird es eine
partielle sonnenfinsternis geben die von
europa aus zu sehen ist
zwischen 9 30 und 12 uhr mittags wird
sich der mond vor die sonne schieben und
dabei 82 prozent des lichts wegnehmen
die letzte finsternis dieser art ist
über zwölf jahre her seitdem hat sich
aber in deutschland eine menge geändert
wir gewinnen zum beispiel 6 prozent
unserer energie aus solarzellen und
genau das wird laut so manchem
netzbetreiber zum problem denn diese
sechs prozent die fehlen uns nun am 20
märz zwischen 9 30 und 12 uhr
und das könnte stromausfälle im ganzen
land bedeuten dagegen behauptet die
hochschule für technik und wirtschaft
aus berlin die sich bereits in einer
studie im vergangenen jahr genau mit
dieser sonnenfinsternis beschäftigt hat
dass es eben diese stromausfälle nicht
geben sollte dass stattdessen werden
pumpspeicherwerke den fehlenden strom
liefern können diese speichern tagsüber
überschüssige energie der solarzellen
und können sie nachts wenn besonders
viel strom gebraucht wird oder eben wer
ansonsten finsternissen abgeben
wer nun am ende recht hat das werden wir
am 20 märz sehen ja und passend zu
unserem solarflugzeug das in fünf
monaten um die welt fliegt kann ich euch
nur das hörbuch in 80 tagen um die welt
empfehlen ein klassiker von jules verne
ein buch über die eine riskante wette
und die globalisierung unserer welt
kostenlos wenn wir hier oben
er klickt oder dem ersten link in der
video beschreibung folgt und wie wir
mehr aus solarzellen rausholen können
erfahrt ihr hier eine studie straße aus
solarzellen für das video hier klicken
allerdings wie immer in der video
beschreibung und
für pixum app und zum blog gibt hier
auch wie immer und auch in dem schreiben
und was meint ihr
also für mich jetzt mal wie wird
verdammt noch mal diese penislänge
gemessen und könnt ihr das bestätigen
naja das ist egal ich würde noch mal
wissen wie das geht und bis dann bleibt
da